my armor is like tenfold shields
my teeth are swords my claws spears
the shock of my tail a thunderbolt my
wings a hurricane
and my breath death middle earth is one
of the richest places for fantastical
creatures and characters
this world of the elves and dwarves and
men are filled to the brim with all
sorts of magical
and monstrous beasts but in this video
we shall fast forward through all the
years in middle earth
and take a look at 9 of the terrible
dragons that were mentioned in all of
j.r.r tolkien's works
it is quite a big debate as to what type
of creatures these dragons were
no one knows if they were actually
original bees that were created by
morgoth
or if there were other reptilian
creatures that were twisted and bestowed
with fiery powers
and great size by him there's also a
section of fans that believe
that the dragons were spirits of maya
that followed morgoth and that they
serve only him and not sauron
which would make sense as they are very
magical in nature
that they are very intelligent and no
things that other beings would not be
able to sense
they have enormous strength fiery power
just like the balrogs
and owe no allegiance to the dark lord
sauron
so with that intro let us dive into the
nine dragons mentioned in tolkien's
works
of middle earth number one glaurum
gularang was the first terrestrial
fire-breathing dragon in middle-earth
he was known as the father of dragons
after his army suffered defeat after
defeat at the hands of the elves
morgoth came to realize that he needed
another even more powerful weapon
something that was the middle earth
equivalent of a weapon of mass
destruction
as such he began to experiment and
glaurung was the result
of these experiments glaurung first
emerged in 260 of the first age and
attacked the elves at the siege of
angban
though glaurong didn't have the wings
and could not fly like the later ones
that would arise he was still the
greatest terror of his time
he however needed more time to mature
and was just a fraction
of his strength during that time glauron
was however most powerful
two centuries later in the battle of the
belarians and was a terror to behold
he was killed by tyrion years later in
an encounter that also saw
the death of turin and his sister
number two and galagon also known as ann
caligon the black
he was the greatest of all the wicked
dragons and the greatest of all the
dragons in fact
to have ever roamed middle earth he was
bred by morgoth during the first age
and was the largest dragon to have ever
existed his appearance in the history of
that world was restricted to the war of
wrath
and had a very abrupt ending being
released during the last
battle and temporarily managed to drive
off the forces of the valar
by his might along with other dragons
his death was in fact for the good of
all
for he would have caused the world to
fall asunder under the rods of his wings
and fire and caligon's size is not
specified but must have been colossal
due to the destruction of the towers of
tharangordrim when he fell on them
which are elsewhere identified with the
three smoking peaks of those mountains
although he could have been way smaller
than the mountains he broke
number three scather scattered worm was
a mighty long worm of the grey mountains
an area north of merkwood and edible and
so he was one of the greatest dragons to
infest that range of the north
little is known of scather's life except
that he possessed a great hoard stolen
from the
dwarves he was slain by fram son of
frumgar
in the early days of the eo theod which
were a rays of north men who flourished
near the veils of the anduin
and later in the northern murkwood areas
scather was believed to be around the
size of smaug
or a little bit bigger scatters
recovered hoard
was the subject of great dispute between
the men of the eotheod
and the dwarves of that region who
claimed that the horde was their own
fram rebuked their claim and sent them
the teeth of the dragon with the words
jewels such as these you will not match
in your treasuries
for they are hard to come by and it was
rumored
later for this insult the dwarves killed
him
number four the fire drake of gondolin
this third dragon on the list also
called the beast of gonolin
was a great dragon who in earlier
versions of j.r.r tolkien's
legendarium participated during the
battle and the fall of gondolin in the
year
510 of the first age so on a bell he
arrived on the western walls of gondolin
carrying many balrogs on its back which
would alone have meant that his size was
enormous
during the ensuing chaos the elf
ecthelion
and tour a man were confronted by the
great dragon and it almost trampled upon
them
tour then healed the foot of the dragon
with his sword
and the fire drake was said to have
spotted flames and scream and
he lashed his tail and killed as many
orcs and got athlete which were
elves in his agony thus duor and
exhalian were able to escape the dragon
but it is still unknown as to how the
beast died
number five the great gold drake cold
drakes were dragons that lacked
the great power of all of middle earth's
most infamous dragons
which was the ability to breathe fire
nevertheless they were strong foes with
iron hard scales
wicked gloves both tails and terrible
fangs though most did not survive the
war of wrath at the end of the first age
some escape eastwards and remain in the
far north above the grey mountains
and in the withered heat as the
millennial passed the cold drakes
multiplied and became a serious threat
to the dwarves in the late third age
eventually war
was declared and in the third age 2589
dane first the king of durian's folk and
his second son flor
was slain at the gates of their own hall
by a gigantic specimen
and this was known as the great gold
drake number six smog
smog is a dragon and the main antagonist
in j.r.r tolkien's
1937 novel the hobbit his treasure
and a mountain he lives in being the
goal of his quest
powerful and fearsome he invaded the
dwarf kingdom of erebor
150 years prior to the events described
in the novel
and was a fire drake of the third age
considered to be the last great dragon
to exist in middle-earth
he was drawn towards the enormous wealth
amassed by the dwarves
of the lonely mountain during the reign
of king throar and laid ways to the
neighboring city of dale
and captured the lonely mountain driving
the surviving dwarves
into exile for 171 years or rather 60 in
the movie timeline
smart hoarded the lonely mountain's
treasures to himself staying within the
mountain until the company of dwarves
managed to enter the lonely mountain and
awaken him from his hibernation
correctly believing that dwarves and
bilbo baggins
had received assistance from the men of
the lake town in entering the lonely
mountain
smart left the mountain to break
destruction upon lake town
nearly destroying azgaroth which is the
lake town before being
slain by bar the bowman with a black
arrow
so before we go on to the lesser known
dragons of middle-earth
do check out our teespring store as we
have new t-shirts
and hoodie designs as well as the old
ones which some of you might not have
seen we have muds tees masks hoodies and
more
so grab one for a friend or for yourself
and by doing that you would be
supporting our channel
thanks mine cuers number seven
one of the fire drakes that were created
by morgoth and most probably one that is
not
of such a great importance was this one
called goster
not much is known about this dragon
except for the fact that it just had a
name
and the name goster in cinderin which
was a language of the elves most
commonly spoken in middle earth
during the third age so his name means
terrible sight
in which gos means terrible and thir
means sight or
expression or face so he was ugly
number 8 dom bombadil's dragon in the
poem called the horde
a certain tom bombadil existed who was
an enigmatic figure
that lived throughout the history of
arda who lived
in the valley of the river with the
window east of the shire
a mysterious being tom lived in the
depths of the old forest close to the
barrow downs
so in the poem the part of the dragon
goes like this
in the early days the elves had might
and power but their doom fell
at this time a dwarf greedily collected
their silver and gold in a cave working
to produce rings
and coins yearning for the power of
kings he turned old and did not hear a
dragon entering his cave
the dragon took his life and took over
the treasure the dragon also became
agent
lying atop the treasure for years he
lacked his fire and gems stuck to his
belly
he knew all the treasures well when he
slept dreaming of thieves and eating
them
a warrior entered the cave and slayed
the dragon
number nine dragons of the war of roth
during the many battles in the war of
wrath and abdel morgoth was defeated
the most important and most well-known
of the dragons was of course angeligon
glarum and the fire drake of gondolin
there were
slight mentions of one or two of the
dragons that helped either of these
other great beasts
so just for namesake we will include
them as the dragons of the war of wrath
which were instrumental in fighting in
the battles of the bellerin and the
final stand of morgoth
and so with that we come to the end of
the list of the nine dragons of middle
earth
so do leave a like if you find this
video entertaining and do leave a
thought
in the comment section and for the new
ones do subscribe for more dragon videos
as well as other monster videos